there are so many reasons to be frantic
to run from one thing to another and to
be pumped high with anxiety and dread
and yet as we know in our hearts it is
even more of a priority to keep an
occasional appointment with someone we
neglect in our normal frenzy a deeper
quieter part of ourselves
we have intimations of it at night on
the motorway or in the gray stillness of
the early morning it seems everything we
do matters so much but to stay sane
we need to hear a different more
humbling message that everything we do
and our is in truth meaningless when
considered from a sufficient distance
from the perspective of the timeless
stones the relentless pounding sees the
infinite heavens from here you can see
Venus and Jupiter in the darkening sky
when dusk deepens you can see distant
stars algebra andromeda aries and the
suggestion of a billion others beyond
the weakness of your field of vision
to counter our tendencies to exaggerate
and panic we need to meditate on our
utter insignificance when measured
against eons of time and space
even on our own planners there is so
much that a strange wondrous other
and completely indifferent to us this is
the village of Raqqa candle near Croce
in Cambodia roughly 500 families live
here about 800 kids go to the local
school the boys play may come in they
put a bottle in a box in the sand and
shoot elastic bands Alice if you hit the
bottle you're the boss
most of the villagers are farmers to
relax they play pool or go to the local
cinema they don't know anything about
you your sorrows the gossip about you
the dilemmas of your career and you till
now you nothing about them
we exist too much in the minds of others
we are perpetual overdramatize errs of
who we are and what we do
we should learn to develop a red ear
awareness of our beautifully miniscule
place in the wider scheme of things to
free ourselves from our constant
debilitating anxieties to bring a little
perspective back to our needlessly tense
and preciously brief lights
you